hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll for
today we're going to go into big data
and storytelling so i remember once
hearing a conversation or maybe reading
about it online where someone was
complaining the usual complaint about
hollywood movies how they're sort of
lowbrow and predictable but
frustratingly popular compared to more
intellectual fare and someone else
gave the counter argument saying that's
because hollywood does what aristotle
told storytellers to do 2500 years ago
to have a structure a three-act
structure dino conflict the whole bit
and there's something to that you know
on the one hand there's plenty of
different kinds of stories they don't
all follow the hollywood three-act
structure on the other hand it can
meanwhile i should say it can be a
little bit predictable but it
nevertheless works you know there's
something about that kind of story that
hooks us that carries us along
and there are other stories that carry
us along in different ways and other
people are fans of those so
given this feeling that stories which
are these quintessentially human
artifacts right given this idea that
they have structure somewhere
wouldn't it be great to do science to
that idea to try to tease out using data
using some kind of collection of
information whether or not real world
stories the stories that we'd like to
listen to and stories that we tell both
spontaneously and
from great planning have different kinds
of structure of this form so that's what
today's guest does peter dodds is a
statistician at the university of
vermont who studies big data kinds of
problems in many different contexts from
earth sciences to
language to ecology but he's one of the
heads of what is called the
computational story lab
and what they do is they consider
individual words and they rank them they
rank these different words or they have
people rank them in all sorts of
different ways right different valences
for are the words happy or sad are they
strong or weak etc and then they ask how
important are these different rankings
how much correlation is there between
different kinds of axes upon which
different words have these values and
they try to seek out using math what are
the most important aspects that words
can have playing a role in a story it
turns out there's a two-dimensional
framework which is very nice
words go from a spectrum of weak to
powerful and also from safe to dangerous
those are the two aspects those are two
axes that matter the most for
the impact that words have in stories
and then you can plot
real stories whether it's novels or
screenplays for that matter you can plot
things like the state of the the
emotional state of the world by looking
at twitter or looking at other social
media i'm not going to give away all the
answers here but peter does a good job
of explaining how stories do have
structure it's not just our imagination
we're not just imprinting structure on
it from inside ourselves there's a real
sense in which successful stories have a
certain kind of flow and it's
fascinating to look at why people
respond to the stories in different ways
which you can look at on twitter right
what kinds of events are causing people
to be happy or sad to take refuge in
words that are powerful or dangerous or
weak or safe or whatever so this is very
early days i think for this kind of work
it's very difficult language humanity
meaning it's all there but we're
beginning to have these big data sets
that let us ask these questions in
really new ways so it's going to be
exciting to see what comes out of this
kind of work so let's go
[Music]
peter dodds welcome to the mindscape
podcast uh thanks uh great to be here i
think a good starting point for this
because as we just said seconds ago
before we started recording uh there's a
lot to cover
uh but i love your invocation of the
famous kurt vonnegut
uh lecture about the shapes of stories
and in some sense you're taking that
idea the shapes of stories and
quantifying it you know like being a
good scientist using the big data
techniques to
nail down some numbers is that more or
less an accurate it's a partial thing
that you do of course but is that an
accurate way of saying one of the things
you're aiming to do
yeah i mean i have this kind of layout
for
basic science and there are sort of two
pieces
fundamental pieces which are describe
and explain
just to sort of make it really simple
and i and i and i do that because i
think it helps students understand which
part they're acting on
uh but but
coming into that is is taste and you
know what what do you choose to work on
what's meaningful what what you know and
that that's hard right but it really
matters tremendously
um you know and sometimes you you're
sort of a bit nervous for maybe years
about whether things will matter i mean
it's the game right so
uh but you know that stories to me have
become more and more
you know
sort of foremost in my mind of of just
this incredibly important aspect of
of being a human and and how cultures
work and and so on and i know many
different fields and just
people in general easily have come to
that right religions
politics you know politics it's all
there uh i came through it from social
contagion trying to think about how
things spread and that was all very sort
of simplistic models you know do you
sort of
you know wear ugg boots or not wear
boots or do you wear a funny hat or not
a funny hat or perhaps you know take on
a political belief or not
but it was all all sort of physics these
sort of models simple things
and they tell important stories about
systems and sort of out of that
eventually over many years started to
sort of think more and more about the
deeper things that people might run
around with which are which are stories
you know and and they can range from
very simple like proverb type stories
um the us has rags to riches write the
american dream it's a really fundamental
kind of story
uh and
trying to you know so how do you then
start to measure those things how do you
right and i'm really
i do come from a physics background i i
i i'm
well i i
couldn't bet that's good yeah um
so you know stat mech kind of stuff so
uh you know
just
if you look back through physics through
thousands of years
we've had some pretty crazy ideas about
how things worked right and that's
that's how science has to progress
but measurement just drove everything
eventually right if you think about one
of my examples that i often put out is
temperature you know measuring
temperature which we take for granted
now but that that took well in the last
500 years hundreds of years to get to a
point where people like oh actually you
can do that we're pretty happy with
measuring distance
you know measuring time really hard yeah
really hard to measure time well yeah i
mean amazing right with sundials for a
long long time
uh and
yeah and and time is a big piece in some
of the work we've done recently too like
how do you experience it but
so um all right that's a bit bit long
but the
i i guess with the big data kind of
revolution and we call it big data
because it's about people i mean we've
had big data in many fields uh
is you know there's this kind of
blue collar kind of honest hard work
that we have to go back to which is just
let's really really look at this stuff
and measure it and quantify it and
um
and you know maybe we had a pretty good
time into the 80s and 90s of making
simple models and telling all these you
know beautiful stories about the world
but they were um you know gloriously
free of data which um you know if you
have a beautiful idea
the
probably don't go look at reality right
because you might you might be sad
yeah so you know and of course string
theory right is you know we've got some
beautiful examples in physics still um
so
although that's beautifully done because
you can't really ever sort it out
uh so so that i feel it's just almost
just being responsible right we're just
trying to measure things well right
we've got these hard problems let's
let's see what we can do and things have
changed tremendously the last 10 to 20
years
all right so vonnegut funny you know i
think i came across this youtube video
of vonnegut talking about it's probably
how i came across it first and i showed
it to my students i'm like this look we
should be able to do this this is this
fits in with work that we've been doing
for many years before which was
measuring
emotional states of of populations and
um some people some people in the
audience might not actually be familiar
with the video so maybe remind us what
vonnegut's actually saying there
yeah so so it's there's sort of a five
minute version you can find i think
because i think he he told the story in
many places it's it's really quite
charming and
uh so he just he sort of lines up a
graph and it's a sort of ill fortune
good fortune on the on the vertical axis
you know good fortune to the top and
then time right so time is the big so
going to the to the right there and and
then marks out a simple
graph and it's uh it just sort of starts
high and then goes down and comes back
up again like a little wave right and
then says this is what he called a
man-in-a-hole story right so this is
this is a
and you know many
sitcoms many stories kind of just work
like this they start off things go wrong
they get back to where they were
uh and and his little sort of line there
was you know people love that story they
love it right it's there's nothing about
plot in here and i want to be really
clear about this is just the overall
emotional arc it gets a bit conflated
with plots and that's that's a much
deeper harder thing that we're trying to
work on as well like
so
emotional like so you think all right
well maybe we can maybe we can do this
and uh
the
the work that we had sitting around
that we built for a long time was this
idea of what we call a hedonometer right
so measuring happiness but equally
sadness i should point out
uh and and that came out of older work
from
that maybe 60 70 years now i think of uh
trying to measure the fundamental
dimensions of meaning and this to me is
really really
i mean this is
i i actually you know this is the most
exciting thing i've
ever worked on the more recent stuff
about that and we'll get to it yeah i
mean just thrillingly incredible uh but
the the idea is okay well let's let's
if i can kind of expand on this like
let's
give yeah give people um
you know so trees cars you know your
life like what
we have all these
aspects of meaning associated with them
how you feel about something and feeling
and meaning allied and interesting ways
so
how do you sort of boil that down right
so we we we have you know maybe you
could look at a dictionary thesaurus and
you've got this rich space of meaning
and the recent more recent work that we
have in
deep learning and so on is like here are
300 dimensions of meaning and it's like
whoa you know what what could go wrong
with that so we're at the absolute other
end of that uh which is what's the
absolutely most essential aspect of
meaning and what was
sort of sort of dug out of them over
decades and through you know of course
initially small scale studies with
people obviously you know students in in
psychology rights the usual game
but here was the idea okay we'll give
you a bunch of objects or concepts or
whatever and you have to just um assess
them on semantic differentials and we'll
give you a bunch of these and so
they are things like hard to soft
good to bad
big to small like all these kind of very
natural things that we're we're fairly
comfortable with them being um
antonyms right that they they represent
opposite ends of some um spectrum
and so we so this was done as i said in
the 40s and 50s and the first big work
was actually for pings from submarines
which is quite charming yeah i mean it's
a really interesting work and it's
so handlers of you know some
people working with radar how did they
feel about the sounds like did it
danger energy what you know what what
did it mean to them
so uh that that kind of spread out from
there into thinking about
meaning of anything
and what was sort of boiled down over
many years was this idea of valence
being dominant and it's a it's a nicely
inscrutable word it just but it does
generally and i think that's not unusual
but it means good to bad basically right
so happy to sad um so collapsing a lot
of things and so you can imagine from an
evolutionary point of view like a sort
of a survival point of view you know
you're an organism you have a sense of
what's good and helpful and positive and
negative and you know you're attracted
to
you know one end and you're repelled
from the other
so it had this very sort of fundamental
aspect to it there are a couple of
dimensions that
came out and the tricky thing is you've
started with hard and soft
you know light and heavy you've started
with all these very sensible ones and
you have to figure out then
because what's really going on you were
solving like an svd type problem a
linear algebra problem you have to
explain what svd means
yeah so singular value decomposition
it's uh
uh what what you're trying to figure out
is if you've got all of these axes like
these semantic differentials
if we just
sort of take the right point of view it
may be that there's some
way of adding them up and subtracting
some from the others to get a really
fundamental kind of dimension like you
might see that this shape in front of
you
so words have points in this space right
there's the you can imagine words or
things but we'll let's let's talk about
words so
i'm going to present you with a word you
know football or chicken and you have to
rate it on all of these different
semantic differentials
so then it has some point
these words have a point in the space of
somatic differentials and then the idea
is we'll rotate that space around and
play with it a little bit and maybe we
see oh it's kind of you know really
dominant in these ways and say that this
valence dimension is that's a sum of all
of these things in some complicated way
but maybe you know the good bad semantic
differential probably lines up with it
so you're taking all these words and you
have many different possible axes along
which your your students i guess or or
subjects are rating them but some
just correlate exactly with others and
sort of that's kind of redundant
information and you're looking for what
are the what are the ways what are the
axes if you like that matter the most is
that a fair way of saying it that's
right that's right and they're not you
know it isn't any one of those semantic
differentials that you started with
necessarily in some
in some way you have to you have to go
through that and figure out yeah okay
these ones are kind of it's you know
it's not like um
mass and length and those sorts of
things right now we're dealing with
categorical it's it's
it so it takes a you have to sit down as
a human i think and really kind of think
through this
uh so so that's right and
and the work that we did initially to
get this hedonomy stuff to work was to
i mean essentially actually many years
ago i'm trying to figure out okay we've
got all this data coming through like
blogs
it was a little bit before twitter and
facebook really took off
um but we looked at some other things
like uh state of the union speeches you
know there's hundreds of years there um
music lyrics for which we had you know
60 70 years so we we're trying to get
hold of different kinds of
text some text as data that represented
some aspect of human behavior you know
none of these things are
complete
of course we wouldn't want to say that
but we thought well we've got the stream
of say
you know words coming through in real
time can we can we figure out like is is
this population that's expressing it
happy or sad or you know are they
fearful or less fearful
and
partly inspired by some of the things
that were coming out of economists
around the time greenspan
2007 and 8
said you know he would throw out all of
these mathematical models if he could
figure out why people are becoming more
euphoric or fearful yeah
it's a i people could probably find that
interview it's on the john stewart it's
on it's on the daily show from a long
time ago and it's a it's quite a
remarkable
it's before the housing crash too yeah
so you know i would carry that around as
a good example like you know that seems
a
a really basic thing to know and and of
course we want to put it up against
something like gdp
you know sure the stock market's up but
are people happier or sadder you know if
we
and and it goes back to measurement if
you want to improve things we're i think
we're in this kind of really difficult
time well we can measure some big
complicated things quite well especially
money or at least we think we can
and but we're leaving out these other
mushier harder pieces to measure and as
a result of course you try to maximize
or optimize something that's and you're
not measuring everything i mean i think
people understand that but you sort of
also forget it you know you look at the
things that have charts like they look
yeah here's the stock market you look
under the land yeah
yeah so
so that was part of our challenge i mean
i think it was a fundamental thing about
people we're trying to measure is
populations and we're not really trying
to we're not trying to track individuals
it's nothing that we would say oh you
said this sentence you're happy or sad
it has to be from many many you know
many many words right so it's more like
a
a physics kind of you're averaging over
lots of pieces so it kind of has an
in-built privacy thing um
if you like
we eventually created something online
which is at hedonometer.org and it it
takes twitter data and that that sort of
the banner thing is twitter and you can
see over
many years now 13 14 years this sort of
long arc of of what's you know twitter's
a complicated thing people have changed
who you know who's actually active on it
i think we have 10 languages russian
korean it's a
it's a whole thing but it's exactly this
kind of
index if you like what's the you know
the dow jones index of of happiness
uh and
it has some big
uh patterns it's it's been going down
actually for five or six years but more
recently has been kind of going up so
the happiness has been going down
yeah for a long time since about 2015
yeah weird yeah going down and uh but
the last uh
last year it's been sort of slowly going
up
2020 was the first time we saw anything
that i would call collective trauma and
um you know i
of course there's your own personal view
of things and and that's what we're
trying to take out of this like what we
think about things we're trying to get
the sense of the population and and you
know your listeners will have all of
their own specific
kind of feelings of how things have you
know maybe 2014 was the worst year you
know personally right but we're trying
to get out the whole picture
and and by collective trauma what i mean
is uh
the advent of
you know the world kind of understanding
there was a pandemic um we we sort of
knew in january 2020 that there were
dangerous things afoot but it wasn't
really till i think it's march 12th
when you know the nba suspended its
season and tom hanks said he had covered
all these things happened in about 10
minutes
and um uh president trump at the time
gave a speech sort of saying for the
first time things weren't great and so
and the stock market of course the stock
market started to tank straight away
um
so so that that was a big drop and it
also did what we'd seen in the past is
there are these big drops for deaths of
celebrities um terrorist attacks
school shootings you know these things
that occupies but then
they they've really quickly been wiped
out by stories you know like the people
still talked about those things but the
there's just this flood of stories all
the time that the you know of everything
that's happening in the world so there'd
be drops but they kind of come straight
back up
maybe a couple of days
but it took on the order of months
really for twitter to sort of rebound
back up to its kind of normal level at
the time which is pretty low
and then george floyd's murder was a
huge drop but it kept dropping as the
protest built over the next few days
because of people understanding what had
happened and being out
expressing their um you know that their
feelings online are what we measured as
feelings and that was that's the lowest
drop we've ever
seen and again it took this a long time
to come out of
january 6 was another big drop actually
that's probably the third lowest over
the whole time
so this was you know that's our whole
the many things have kind of us come out
of all of that where you can measure
happiness of texts in lots of ways and
to finally get back to bonnegut what we
did was we went to books and we said all
right let's see what he could this is
this idea of vonneguts and he actually
you know he says
this is so simple even computers could
do it you know this is maybe
1995 when he was saying these things
and we thought all right we can probably
do it and
uh so so
so
and in fact it turns out that i think in
maybe when was it 60s or 70s he had
he had i think it was the university of
chicago he wanted to do this as a
master's thesis right he had presented
it and and they said no and he was still
mad about that for decades and decades
and decades you can find him
you know talking about how that how
upsetting that was to him uh so so it's
sort of a
an homage to him in some ways but uh we
we
you know we got a bunch of books maybe i
think twenty thousand um you have to
sort out what's fiction it's a bit of a
mess
uh but basically
created this same hedonometer idea but
in this case you're now sliding through
the book so you're gonna say okay a
thousand the first thousand words have
this score and then we'll slide this
little window okay and we're not reading
it like a person right we're just
it's like sometimes called a bag of
words method you're just going to put
them all together
and and slide
and get a score for them right so
not all words we have scores for right
and in some words we
you know say that the score is is um
unimportant like the word the is a
neutral word you know we ask people what
they think of that word right so we
as i said we had psycho people deal with
psychology students of course early on
you know eventually it's online you deal
with mechanical turk which is an amazon
service where you you ask people what
what they think about things
um
or you can use it to all sorts of things
but uh so so the you know this the scale
of these studies is now really quite
large so you you have
scores for words yeah so you sort of
separately score the individual words
and now you're you're taking novels or
what have you works of fiction and
uh
scoring as you say sections of those as
as you go through the text and so you
can see the happiness or the sadness go
up and down as you read through the text
right and you play around with the
window size and you think about this and
we did it for movie scripts as well
scripts are useful they have
descriptions of what's going on so it's
you know they're actually somewhat rich
um you can't get the final one which i
realized
as we were doing this because i was
looking at alien
and i was looking through the script and
ripley as a man um in the
what it might be the fourth the last
script version of that anyway so you've
got some version of it and um and you
you do what you can so
uh you know if you look at something
like predator starts okay and then just
goes to like it's terrible you know like
it's just negative and drops there's no
there's no sort of you know ups and
downs and which we're more familiar with
with stories like so you know harry
potter the last
uh the
definitely hello is the the last book
you know
really huge ups and downs as it goes
through right so
and you know i think that's
we we sort of think we're trying to
figure out what's is there sort of
characteristic scales of right of of
fiction
uh so but what came out of that and and
we attacked in various ways but there
are sort of six fundamental
shapes if you like and and
there was uh rags to riches one so very
simple basically sort of goes up
throughout the book you know may have
some
ups and downs but that's sort of a you
know this is like kind of like
decomposing something into
you're decomposing a sound you know into
its fourier waves or whatever yeah it's
a bit like that
and i want to add something that's much
more complicated though so but this is
this is of course we're looking at
motion arc so we do have signals there's
the um tragedy where things just keep
going down so metamorphosis may be kafka
right it starts off it starts off badly
your cockroach should start with and
then it keeps going down
uh and then there's the man and the
whole type one of vonnegut there's the
op the inverse of that which we call
icarus right so it starts things go
really well and then they go really bad
uh and then we had two others which were
cinderella and oedipus right so
cinderella starts low goes high you know
you've gone to the ball with this fairy
godmother stand up and then things go
badly again and then then you know so
there's a huge rise and that's one of
vodka's faint you know favorite little
stories that he talks about cinderella
fitting this pattern
so it's a simple you know down up down
up and the flip of that we had we called
that oedipus right starts well things go
bad
then you kill your father and marry your
mother you know like it ends it ends it
ends it ends poorly and it's poorly um
so i mean yeah just to because sadly we
don't have the visuals here for the
audience but this is as i was
i saw your plots though the visuals are
great and uh
plots in the sense of graphs not plots
in the sense of story structures but uh
it is a it's
i mean what what fraction of stories fit
into these because it's a very simple
kind of exposed facto
natural thing there's there's sort of
the the stories that have
no maxima or minima in the revolution
right it's either rights or riches or
tragedy and then there's stories with
one maximum or minimum and the stories
with two maxima or minima in that basic
arc is that like are those six
possibilities
uh what fraction of stories covered by
that
i mean it's
some you know it's it's again one of
these things where it's like 90 95 it's
amazing yeah
but of this particular pool of books
right so you know and this set of
works so i think the future of this of
course is to curate things really well
like here are
here are detective stories here are
stories from this particular culture and
so on so so it becomes a
and we found this with the hedonomy work
in general if you estimate the happiness
of a set of words you might say okay
maybe i can get an error measure for
that right this is a very typical thing
to do with measurement but it turns out
it was completely in the lens it's
completely in the words the list of
words for which you have scores so if
you change that list of words by scoring
more or taking some out you know that's
where the error is it's all in the
instrument so you know this in this case
yeah we're
we have a it's one of those things where
we seem to have a big data set we have
20 000 books you know that's a hard
thing to read right so this is gets
beyond it right i mean it's important it
gets beyond it's no one's gonna read 50
million tweets a day right and so
what we're trying to do is what what
i've sort of called telenomics which is
like distant measure sensing of
knowledge right so far
it's a genomics like far knowledge
and and because yeah there's no way an
individual can do that uh and we want to
get some sense of what you know the
whole thing sort of streaming all these
tweets streamed past you in three
seconds how would you feel
pretty bad probably just yeah
but you know taking that part out you
know was it is a better or worse than
yesterday
i want to say that the um
the the man and so the man in the hall
one which which is this favorite one of
vonnegut so i
i would say that the the framing of that
is is is not great actually because i
mean you know he's sitting there he has
a drawing so you can like we're
struggling here with the podcast but you
know he has a drawing so you can kind of
see it in front of you it all makes
sense but men and whole doesn't tell you
a sense of time it doesn't give you a an
arrow right so metamorphosis could be
men in a deepening hole as that turns
out but you know a person in a hole
it doesn't tell you that they start okay
they get into the hole and they get out
i know what the and i i guess i think a
lot about ads and slogans and so on and
it struck me before
the 2016 election that make america
great again was the man in a whole heart
and it was in four words it tells you
about
you know it indicates something about
the past the present and the future
which is
you know really powerful and it's
as i understand it's 1980 i think it's
uh reagan and bush it was used in ads
like let's make america great again it
was used in posters and so on it wasn't
quite the
dominant slogan um but it it's one of
those ones that's really
powerful bill clinton used it lots of
people have used it over the years in
various ways because it is it is very
powerful i mean and i think that you
know as a rhetorical as a as a story in
four words
you know super powerful and do you find
that there are you lose this a little
bit but
relationships between these different
kinds of story arcs or valence arcs
whatever you want to call them and
genre or literariness of the fiction i
mean are there certain kinds of uh or do
you get highbrow fiction using one kind
of pattern and uh pot boilers using
another one
you know we are working on that more now
uh we have some work where we're
looking at things like accounting
textbooks and um
you know manuals for televisions and you
know just like
what happened because you want to know
like are we getting something artificial
it's certainly if you randomly shuffle
text it's it's you know it doesn't
produce these shapes right there's i
mean as you might hope right so there's
sort of a
we can at least get that um sorted out
uh but again that's a curation of data
and uh that that i think we're still
um behind on we're trying to build well
we do have this thing called story
wrangler that's at storywrangling.org
and it's for twitter at the moment but
the idea is to
kind of house all of these different
bodies of work
and have a time series for their
usage of words within them so
that hopefully eventually will be
something that could kind of you know go
towards what you're saying we do of
course have google books which has been
around you know for about 10 years now
um
the problem with that i think is is that
it doesn't have enough metadata you
can't really sort out this sort of
broadly fiction okay broadly everything
and as it turns out we
we you know did some work on it and we
figured out that uh actually the the
kind of collective english stuff is full
of science
there's a lot of medical and science
type writing and the 20th century is
basically
dominated by the sort of rise of science
and you can see it in little details
like
figure with a capital f it just goes up
and like you know ed et
and all the things to do with data
really actually about the
that exponential growth of of science
which is sort of
understood i suppose in the 60s to solar
price
um presumably armed with a million
graduate students went through libraries
figuring out you know what what the
memory was in journals and and how much
stuff was being published and anyway
that's imprinted in there in a way that
we can't uh well it makes sense i i
think i noticed on your web page that
the most commonly used word on twitter
is rt the abbreviation for retweet
that doesn't really mean it's the most
commonly used in english but on that
particular medium that's what pops out
right and you have to say you know what
what are you right what are you looking
at twitter is interesting because it
does kind of encode
so much and the news is for sure there
i mean another way to look of all all
this is to think about you know forests
right so we have a forest and you would
like to know all the species in the in
the forest which is actually of course
very hard to measure um and have
accounts for them right how many are
there of all these different species so
this is this
comes out of linguistics but the types
and tokens distinction like how what are
the
all of the you know what's your your
lexicon which would be for language
here's your list of words um and then
here's your list of all the animals and
organisms yeah and then you have next to
it that counts right but then you want
to do that over time so
maybe for forest it's at the scale of a
year um there are studies that do this
for small parts of forests but that's
the kind we're sort of looking at
forests of words and stories and trying
to see how they change over time and of
course
they can change dramatically
i mean let me i don't want to lose track
of um this other thing that we mentioned
and then we sort of buried it in the in
the happiness versus sadness discussion
but there are this there is this
multi-dimensional way of thinking about
the words and you you've done your
factor analysis to try to figure out
what dimensions matter the most and uh
why don't you tell us what what those
dimensions are that matter the most
yeah i actually just wrote that down um
so the
so this has been i think i'm i'm really
excited i mean it's still in
review so we'll see what happens but
we're we're pretty confident about all
of this so
all right so we had valence and this and
when we sort of saw that at the time in
the literature that this these were the
dominant this is the dominant axis and
certainly when you look at the data back
then um and i think we're looking at
data sets that had a thousand words with
scores associated with them
so it's not a big set of words right
people's vocabularies are tens of
thousands you know something like
twitter with all its misspellings is
hundreds of people yeah
so but you know you want something on
that order and over time what has
happened um of course there have been
bigger studies done
and done in slightly different ways and
uh so we've gotten just as you might
hope in science you know more accurate
richer
works
back then 12 13 years ago the
the main idea of what was going on was
there was valence which is this happy
sad good bad kind of axis
and there were a couple others though
one was um about
dominance like do you feel in control or
not in control
when you when you kind of consider
something
and there was another one which is
activity it's very got various you know
names for it but basically kind of
activation is this exciting or boring
so there have been these other sort of
secondary dimensions that people have
had floating around and then sort of
debates about which ones matter
okay so we've got this work from
we didn't do this this study but a
couple of years ago it's worked by
muhammad in canada
again
online many many people
doing these evaluations and now we've
got twenty thousand now it's twenty
thousand points right so there's a huge
jump from
say a thousand and work that we did
which got to ten thousand
and they're mostly good kind of words
right they don't have people's names or
events which can be a bit of a an issue
with some of these
large sets of words
all right so
the idea was
that you the people were going to
evaluate these on valence and what was
called arousal which is the activation
one and dominance right so you're given
these three dimensions and and that it
is tricky how do you present that to
people so you kind of have to give them
kind of clouds of words at each end
right so they kind of know
that you know the positive end of
valences you feel good you feel happy
you feel maybe comforted you know there
it's it's a bit spread out
but that's fine everyone's given that
same
you know uh those same instructions
but looking harder at this stuff and
then again doing this kind of factor
analysis um you can see you've got this
kind of now it's a three-dimensional
space you've maybe the
maybe it doesn't come back like in the
dimensions you've actually tried to
impose that that you've tried to say to
people you know we think these are the
fundamental dimensions
that's good but you can see like what
they actually think you know maybe they
correlated some of them yeah and that
actually turns out to be the case and if
you sort of rotate this football and
kind of squeeze some of the axes and
pull some of them apart you get another
shape
and it has these two main well we played
around with for a while but it has these
two main axes and the one going across
if you like horizontally is powerful
power up weak right so so power over
here is like for people would be success
triumph if you if you sort of go back to
people um
so it's kind of winning and then the
week end of that is void and nothing
so it's not failure it's it's just
emptiness so that's going across the
page and then up
uh is pointing up and you know this is
our choice danger so this is like a
compass
for for basic meaning and so danger is
up and safety is down
and we call this
all right we make up words but who's it
or geometry right uh so uzio means uh
you know i mean we're taking it to mean
essence it's a greek word uh but it is
where the word essence comes from so ous
o-u-s-i-a
and we felt
i mean it's fun to make upwards but it
was also like it's not semantics it's
not semiotics it's and we're not
measuring meaning we're measuring and
that's somehow it's depicted we don't
want people to think that we're
measuring essential meaning if you just
still everything down
so we've tried this out with many
different um corpora so things like the
sherlock's sherlock holmes novels and
stories short stories um jane austen's
works so they're sort of you know famous
authors and then a huge collection of
fiction from google with sort of
complicated things but it's 120 years so
that's everything sort of smudged
together equally
um
wikipedia a snapshot of wikipedia which
is a
you would think
of just a different object
uh talk radio so that's transcriptions
of talk radio so now we're going for
you know spoken word it's been turned
into text but that's a different it's
spontaneous it's different it includes
everything from you know npr to sort of
shock jock stuff right so it's a it's a
big grab bag
um the new york times is what 20 years
of the new york times
and so we look so so this is this type
token distinction again right so that
sort of first work where we found this
danger safe axis and power weak access
was looking at types like every word
got one vote yeah and so we kind of
figure it out
and that's that's good but it's just the
substrate and then you have to go and
see what people actually
you know what in these different venues
and beyond
how do they use these how often do they
use these now i want to do this with all
of my podcast episodes i have
transcripts for all of them i want to
know which ones are powerful or weak or
dangerous or safe
yeah no i mean it's i mean we kept and
when those ones are just listed you know
we didn't do them all at once they were
sort of like you'd kind of like corral
the data and then kind of do the same
analysis again i remember every time
thinking will this be different what
what you know what's going on they're
all a little bit different of course but
all of them have what i'll call is the
safety bias that the predominance of
words that people use
uh are in this in this lower
half of this kind of this this disc if
you like and
and it's words that are
trend trend towards being
safe you know at the bottom uh things
like um
uh comfort uh if you want to go out to
safe week you get the words like sofa
and tortoise
um
and then you know safe and and powerful
words like wisdom
and happiness they're they're that's a
real and that turns out that quadrant
that's
what i'll call the safe powerful
quadrant is sort of lines up with
positivity and happiness
and there's this much older work
that we built on
when we looked at large text which is
which came up with this idea of the
pollyanna
principle that in general interactions
between people and so this communication
of all kinds there are more positive
aspects than negative ones
it's a bit surprising to people i think
because you know it's easy to kind of
bring to mind
arguments or negativity on maybe a line
or the news is terrible you know these
sorts of things but if you think you
know society exists it can not exist but
it does exist and it does hold together
for lots of little sort of positive
interactions
and i
so this was work this is maybe six or
seven years ago
what was so i mean i didn't expect this
was surprising it sort of popped out
that there are more positive words than
negative words that's just
and it's true across
we looked at 10 major languages 24
corpora you know russian german
korean indonesia so we um we we looked
at a lot of different
different pieces there and it really
kept coming out so
uh and and you know there's a sort of a
story there i mean that that it's
languages are great social technology
right we're excited about snapchat or
something but you know really language
is this an unbelievable thing that we
have money is another one i suppose you
know because we've somehow encoded
belief into this abstract thing it's
pretty good i remember correctly though
that uh in
fictional stories in particular there's
more danger than you might expect or i
mean then then you have an ordinary
language because obviously a story wants
to be exciting somehow
um it's a good question if it's more so
so all of them have on average a
positivity bias okay
now there are parts where they dip
below into this negative
side of things but you know if you look
at music lyrics one of the first things
we looked at the way and they kind of
told us that we were getting somewhere
the rankings so at the bottom is heavy
metal
right
yeah well this is sort of like ranking
like taking john this is something where
we were and you did ask about genres of
fiction but this is actually something
where we did have genres um
and uh on this this is on the happiness
one okay so this is yeah and at the top
is gospel and soul right so it kind of
makes it the ordering looked pretty good
for this very rudimentary instrument
we've made but even you know heavy metal
it was still above neutral on average
right it's still good to know even
though yeah it's just still about so if
you look at a you know maybe harry
potter or something like when things go
bad it does dip into this this negative
thing which is pretty hard because
you've got to use a lot of negative
words because on average the bulk of
words are over in the positive side of
things
or at least you know there's a skew
towards positivity
so the generalization of that now is
that in fact it's a safety
bias that we're not just it's not really
positive it's it's that we're using more
safer words
dangerous words you know they're
incredibly important they describe
all these things that can go wrong we
just don't
use them as much and when we use them of
course they are incredibly meaningful
but so so happiness is is basically yes
is is safety plus power
and and one of the things the other
thing that i thought was really
fascinating was
different stories that you looked at
have chara you can associate characters
in the narrative with you know along
this dangerous versus safe and powerful
versus weak axis
and i guess harry potter had like all
sorts of characters like you know
they're dangerous ones weak ones etc
whereas in game of thrones almost
everyone's powerful and a lot of them
are very dangerous
it was more like a clash of extremes in
that in that way
so that that work again it's like
completely thrilling to me this is just
incredibly exciting because this comes
from a completely different data set so
this is a sort of an online thing again
not something we did but
but it went back to giving people
characters from stories and
there are a lot of tv shows and movies
but there's also
pride and prejudice right so there's
some some books are in there um
and
zooming out and presenting it's about
a hundred it might be 200 but 150 of
these semantic differentials so sort of
going way back in time in a way and
giving people
you know that but so it's for characters
so there's country
city
you know that kind of rich poor there
are things that may be a little more you
know clearly
assigned to people
uh so so we were able to sort of start
again with a
really rich set of semantic differential
and i think there are about 800
characters that we looked at over 90
different i'll call them story verses
right there's buffy the vampire slayer x
files you said game of thrones it's a
arrested development is in there it's
really a a big spread so i think there's
something for everyone right you might
not know
80 of them but there will be some that
you could look at so
uh so so this is a completely different
data set and doing this analysis again
and you know
turning things around and kind of
rotating spaces
and not really doing anything funny
we're we're saying we're desperate to
find this power danger thing it really
popped out
for free so this is something that's
just you know very sort of supportive of
what we've done in this other space and
there is a third dimension i should
mention that one because it's
in general it's about what we call
structure so structured to unstructured
so a rock you know has has a stronger
structure level
um
cardinal
bureaucracy
bass right these are these are
considered more structured but clown and
conical and tickle
these are these are words that go out
confetti they're considered unstructured
and so for characters it's playfulness
it's much more about playfulness
so someone like
you know robin hood right is is has a
playful measure on them or mulder from
the x-files is is playful scully is not
playful
not a lot of playfulness in game of
thrones pretty much all of them are in
the danger
pretty much all of them are in the
dangerous powerful
quadrant which is the dominant you know
these are the this is like dangerous
winning basically you know things can go
wrong for you
uh except for um
i'm going to get his name oh
samwell tarly if you know that charlie
yes
so he's he's in he's down in the kind of
the the angel character so jane bennett
is there from pride and bridges these
are people who are
um
you know they they're they're more
towards the safe
um axes they're still in somewhat
powerful but they're more than safe so
these are just really really good people
that's who you find down the bottom
um
if you go around
safe into the kind of weak quadrant then
you get people who tend to you know
they're not bad people but they tend to
get run over
and again and out in the weak side you
get mike you know michael scott from the
office
homer simpson is out there
you know and then i wanted to say that
if you go further up you get this is
where joffrey is from game of thrones
there aren't many from game of thrones
in this what's what's the dangerous weak
quadrant yeah okay and that's they're
chaos agents
they're the chaos agents
and again i guess this might be future
research but you have this
time series you know how the valence of
the story itself evolves page by page
and now you're saying there's a there's
a different set of analysis with sort of
the the distribution of characters uh or
distribution of whatever events and and
so forth um and how
if you just gave me that like if you
didn't tell me the plot right or the
characters or the setting or whatever
how much could i learn how much i infer
about the story just by thinking about
you know both how it evolved over time
and what kinds of characters it involved
do we know that yet
i i mean we are really trying to do that
and and i think it it's remarkable
so i sort of think of character as the
shortcut to story right so
what we as what are stu you know what do
we do with stories right a lot of them
are about prediction they're about
telling us how the world works
um proverbs do this
stories that we listen to like these are
ways that your life can go or maybe
other people's lives can we're trying to
make sense of the world
and and there are certain
yeah we we tend to have stories wrapped
around individuals which i think is
interesting because we want to be in
them so it's hard for us to tell stories
about systems and that's why
yeah i mean when it comes to complex
systems and all this sort of formula
that scientists work on
it's really hard right because people
want to anthropomorphize everything
they absolutely do and i understand that
drive but it's
it's it's it's it's hard it's it's hard
for us to tell the story so but i think
one of the things so you know stories
are incredibly important sort of what
i'm trying to say but we we also can
shortcut them
by
just saying oh here here are what these
characters like here are archetypes and
and we sort of know what will happen if
you say here are these three people on
the hero there we we can kind of try to
predict what will happen
um
so i think they're like little kind of
wind-up toys right so you know in our
brains we will try to simulate we'll run
the dynamical system of these characters
interacting
um it it's it's very natural we want to
do it we want to predict
um and you know to a fault obviously uh
so what we're trying to do
now with this is
this is tough but you want to uh get the
this sort of danger power profile around
a character
and how it might evolve through a story
as well
uh there's the temporal network of which
characters are interacting with each
other we should be able to get that out
uh and with the environments right and
there are you could imagine doing this
for you know star wars or lord of the
rings or something like that or you know
pride and prejudice any any of these
pieces so
what
can we kind of trace that through and it
might be pretty rough you know we divide
books into thirds or something but then
we could you know do a hundred thousand
stories and and get out what are the big
patterns
uh breaking in and seeing seeing this
kind of this two-dimensional space has
been you know very helpful in a lot of
ways i mean i think it's really what it
is
another space we've looked at perhaps
just to start with is is twitter because
we've worked on that a lot but looking
at um
at least what was expressed on twitter
for the january six right the the the
attack on the capital what you see there
is
you know just taking all the tweets and
and scoring them
is
you know measures it's sort of these
these measures of energy like high
energy that i sort of mentioned before
and um
happiness kind of goes down but really
what you see on this kind of compass of
essential meaning is that it really
points straight to danger it actually
goes straight to danger right so sorry
upwards danger um which is you know
danger is kind of high energy plus
badness in a way is sort of
to use these kind of other frameworks
um and
it so so in that respect you'd see it
you know it goes down as being a sad
thing on our hedonometer but that's just
a projection
onto that axis right it's a shadow of
the real
direction which was pure danger
that's very interesting especially
because one of the questions i was going
to ask was
if you're looking at happiness versus
sadness on twitter that's obviously a
very interesting thing but when i
actually looked at the data you know
everyone's happy on holidays that that
that's a clear winner right christmas uh
or at least you put out your happy
tweets on christmas and then everyone's
sad when there's a terrorist attack or a
shooting okay uh but other events like a
presidential election um are more of a
mixed bag
and i'm wondering if there are
the simplest possible thing i can think
of is just a measure of the variance
right like is it something where a whole
bunch of people are happy and a whole
bunch of people are sad at an election
result or is that something that you've
quantified
yeah we have it we just haven't put it
on the site um
i and i think that's you know you're
exactly right so how much uh you know to
what degree are people in unison about
something um and for the extreme things
just in some ways they have to be right
just for those scores to be so high and
so low
uh
but you know so you're quite right so
there is a predictability to the big
spikes in positivity and there there are
just annual holidays right and so people
are using the you know the expressions
of that time you know even happy
valentine's day now
if you look at the words being used and
compare them maybe to some other dates
you can see
that there's really some negativity in
there as well it's being swamped by this
kind of positive right so so valentine's
day will have lonely
right
but it's it's being kind of wiped out
and christmas might have that as well
or so it's a
it's it's not so you want to be a little
careful there just it's not like
everyone is you know doing that they're
right there and you can see for days of
the week so saturday is generally the
most positive day tuesday is generally
the most negative day
but saturday you know it has movies
weddings you know like there's lots of
positive things that might happen on
saturday
but it also has board and hangover
you know there are some
not you know not all it's not all great
for everyone on a saturday and there's a
daily rhythm too right
yeah there's a strong daily rhythm which
i
kind of
i think it's actually in science mexican
i have this line which is uh it's the
daily unraveling traveling of the human
mind
so we kind of i know sleep remains a
mystery but i think we need to be
rebooted because i think we just become
emotionally unstable by the end of the
day you know that's that's i'm
being funny but you see swearing goes up
through the day cursing goes up through
the day and um you know things yeah and
then like you sort of say the variance
goes up as well the emotional variance
goes up through the day so people start
off
fairly tight like things are okay but
it's not emotionally varied as well
right the the yeah and then the wheels
kind of come off as collectively i mean
if you're if one is being a little bit
um
skeptical here is it possible that you
know i might think a lot of people are
happy at 7 p.m because they're enjoying
dinner or movie or whatever but those
people are not on twitter right
how much of a bias do we have by the
fact that twitter is our data stream
here
yeah no that's a it's a weird selection
but i will
i will say that more generally if you
zoom out it does match up with gallup
polls okay right which
which is um
kind of wild right and then we've done
some we have some other instruments
there's one we call the lexico
calorimeter which takes in phrases from
twitter
and assigns them as to whether they're
kind of foodstuffs or about exercise and
then assigns calories to them
and so it's at the state level for the
u.s
but the rankings you get out of that
because you sort of get those calories
in calories out which we're not you know
we're not sort of it's a very rough
silly thing
but it matches it
it uh lines up with um obesity rates
so you can tell which states have higher
obesity raised from twitter is what
you're saying
yeah
and you can look at what you can look
what they're talking about right so you
know colorado does come out number one
vermont at least in this time we looked
it was sort of three i think
but had a
i was overly fond of talking about bacon
which didn't which sort of pushed down i
would have thought you know coloradans
are pretty healthy outdoorsy people
i don't know yeah so there's lots of
skiing and running and bikes but a lot
of those words are there a lot of bacon
and donuts yeah
well well that that whole thing is quite
amazing to look at because the the
ground state though if you like forever
what what's being expressed in terms of
food and and exercise is pizza
and watching television because we have
a lot of activities and some of them
include like lying down as an activity
okay but watch watching television
is one so
so the states differ from that but their
baseline is pretty
uniform in terms of what is being
expressed and of course that's
advertising that's all sorts of things
it's a it's a bit of a melange of inputs
and
this
brings back something that you mentioned
right at the beginning and i thought it
was actually
i mean maybe i had not thought this way
before but i really certainly should
have which is that
we very often talk about the
uh traveling of ideas and sharing and
contagion of ideas or notions or
opinions through social networks and
other networks right an idea might be
you know your universal health care or
uh the right to bear arms but
stories can also uh
travel through these information
networks and narratives and is that
either something you've done or is it a
target to sort of
tease out which stories which narratives
are being shared and how useful they are
because i'm certainly willing to believe
that
a good compelling narrative uh wins
every day over a set of facts no matter
how true they are
yeah i have this thing where i say
something like um never never bring
statistics to a story fight right i mean
it's it's not going to work out for you
so you've got to you should bring the
numbers but you've got to bring stories
as well right i mean it's just just how
we kind of operate and of course people
in politics people you know in in
religion understand this have been
telling
figuring out how to tell stories about
things for a long time
uh so it's absolutely a
long-term ambition to do that it's very
hard but
uh what
what you know we have this sort of
framing of story wrangle like how do you
get out the stories that people are
expressing around an event as it happens
and then maybe long term so say the
parkland shootings uh shooting happen
it's a terrible event just to pull one
out of the many um how do you
sort of track the stories that emanate
from that
and i by that time in history i was
pretty sure that there would be a lot of
conspiracy theory type things and sure
enough like i remember going on youtube
the next day and just searching for
parkland and 18 of the top 20 hits which
is sort of presented as 20
were conspiracy theory things about um
you know that was all faked it's false
flag and so on
so how do you measure that in real time
i i mean this is this is
an enormous
enormous goal that's it's very hard and
then and
then you know so maybe there's a
blossoming of stories after some event
because there's just confusion which
ones are then fighting against each
other
which ones start to to to win
i have notions of stories you know um
kind of having hierarchies to them you
want to be able to tell your story
simply and and that's where slogans i
think you know have this great effect
um
and they they might not be tethered to
some bigger story uh certainly religions
work in that way you want to be able to
sort of say things quickly you know it's
this hierarchy of narratives that you
want to be able to deliver
no i
it's it's
i it's an incredibly difficult problem
but i but i think um i think that
framing is
is
well i went to the right one but i think
it's a very powerful one to be thinking
about what are the stories people are
telling and how much are they reducing
stories to sort of characterization
you know just so for example pizzagate
that story is
pretty
out there right i mean
right it's pretty out there that there
there's a basement in this comet ping
pong place and there are
terrible things happening to children
and there's a cabal and all this sort of
stuff
that's a little hard to grasp but i
think the access in there is really
through
character and so
hillary clinton for example being
characterized as a as a this evil person
as you know to use folklore kind of
things as a witch
then you say this story about her and
you're like sure because she's
she's the devil or if you know someone
else is sort of framed as a godlike
character they can do no wrong and and
you say some story about them that
suggests they've done a bad thing it
gets it's deflected it's washed away you
know what are the defense mechanisms
built into stories this is a really big
part you know how do you how do stories
become hermetically sealed or story
verses if you like yeah i mean i know
that politicians are very focused on the
idea that they want to paint their
opponents and themselves uh in certain
ways like there's certain kinds of
criticisms you can make that that just
don't stick to certain people because
they don't fit the narrative in exactly
that way and finding exactly that kind
of weak point how do you
paint someone as a bad character in a
way that is consistent with what people
already think about them is
one of the secrets to political success
thing i've seen i've thought about with
this danger power kind of framework is
is is a flipping between saying your
opponent is dangerous
and weak
yes and and it doesn't seem to matter
right i mean we sort of know that in
politics you can kind of say lots of
things and if it doesn't stick it you
know you just keep moving on but they
tried they're very they're really trying
and you know in our framework orthogonal
attacks right they sort of literally
orthogonal attacks so you're trying to
say this person is is in a sense quite
powerful and dangerous or you know maybe
the next day you want to say you know
they're feckless and weak and that's a
that's a sort of a kind of a funny
attack um so
really
incredibly
hard problems and and look there's a
there's a
huge danger to this as well right i mean
being of course being able to manipulate
stories and and
kind of measure them and do all these
sorts of things and see what the weak
points are in a system disinformation
people
work on this all the time
i think one of the
something i keep reflecting on is you
know for scientists and um and
journalists my so my wife's a journalist
and there's i always sort of think of
journalists as scientists with a
deadline so
we're trying to figure things out and
tell the truth about something and kind
of explain things right yeah broadly is
a big piece
um
that's a huge battle for us because this
the possible stories you can come up
that come up with that are not true
but are favorable to a viewpoint or a
culture or whatever uh infinite right
there's just an incredible number of
things to maybe you know what's adjacent
to the true story
you could you can really explore some
stuff and find the stories that will
spread faster
that will you know
tack on to people's existing beliefs
so that you know that just is gonna be a
challenge it's always been a challenge
it's just
in sort of a time of
so much information right so much
availability so much ability to
curate and kind of create story verses
that are misleading
um online that you can be taken into
it's it's it's you know we we have to
work really hard on this this is hot so
i went to the webpage for the heat
denominator uh i encourage everyone to
check it out and it's searchable right
you can look for all sorts of wonderful
things and so just to normalize my own
expectations i search for the frequency
of the word quantum because this is
something i'm interested in and it
doesn't have a lot of you know uh high
rates of appearance in news stories but
occasionally and
what you find is probably
what i should have expected ahead of
time which is that there's a sort of
baseline which is pretty normal and
there are spikes and the spikes are
pretty extremely noticeable but i don't
know what the spikes are from right i
mean clearly there was some story about
a quantum computer or something like
that uh maybe my book came out i don't
know but that would be great
um but so how much of that
sort of uh
back engineering reverse engineering can
you do when you see something weird
happening in the data
uh oftentimes in the big stories you
just know what it is but is is are there
objective procedures for figuring out
why the words are shifting in these
different ways on different days
yeah so a number of pieces here this has
been an eternally interesting difficult
problem um what happened yeah like what
happened right and and i remember early
on you know maybe 15
even 20 years ago looking through google
trying to find out what happened on a
particular day right it was kind of hard
like
and and then wikipedia emerges and if
you would of course has
has entries for every
date of history sort of i suppose now
but um but certainly in the modern times
and they're sort of weird lists it's
just a weird list of things that
happened in the world you know there was
a star trek convention there was you
know this war started i mean it's a real
mixture as a concert
so
with with some of what we've got there
story wrangling for example if you click
on a
on a point it will it will take you to
twitter and search twitter for that date
and you will it will sort of show you
which tweets are being amplified
potentially
so tweets get deleted it's a bit of a
problem so maybe it doesn't hold up but
that's something we
and you know what it depends on the sort
of restrictions you have we have 10 of
all tweets going back to 2008 but we
can't
you know sort of share them and put them
out wholesale so we tried to
do something there by pushing it back
into the
you know the actual structure itself of
twitter
google books for example you can't
really it's harder to do that right so
it's harder to go back and search for
google trends you kind of want to figure
out like why is this thing being talked
about so at least i think with twitter
we we have that to some extent
we have another big body of work which
really is connected to this trying to
figure out
exactly this what happened on a
particular day or in a particular week
and we did it around trump
um just
i mean it's president it matters
um it's a very good test case
uh and and i think it certainly
2015 2020 and kind of you know still now
really what i call a turbulent time
story story turbulence has been really
high right so
excuse me the
turnover of stories has just been
kind of incredible and i remember sort
of thinking in 2016-17 like
especially 2017 i think
can you remember what happened the last
two weeks
can you say you know and so it was a
challenge right there could be massive
events like space force or something or
you know you could just resolve
something sort of
yeah there's always something and i you
know look the world's a rich place but
it was a an effort to sort of study that
so we have this uh thing which is kind
of computational timeline
reconstruction and it works through
twitter but it could work through
anything so we could do it through say a
state has archives for example
going back in time or or any kind of
news source you know maybe the new york
times
what what are the sort of narratively
dominant terms like
words and pairs of words that kind of
pop up and these kind of act then like
keywords into bigger stories so they're
not
telling you
say you know buying green land it
doesn't tell you like the whole story of
greenland but it would um you know this
is referencing trump but it would it
sort of pointed out um
but you know early on what we were able
to see there early on was uh that
there's there was a lot of turbulence in
that first year 2017. there was just a
lot of change over
um
uh
there were also just natural disasters
so hurricane maria and so on so these
things came on but there was north korea
you know sort of provocations and then
charlottesville happened the next week
it's it's hard to remember the orderings
of these things so so it it we have a
timeline that you know that kind of
comes out computationally and what you
see in 2020 is just this really just
sudden change into coronavirus because
we called covert chronovirus initially
from for many months just being the
dominant story
every day for months and
we have a measure we call it chronopathy
you can see that time functionally
slowed down because there was just not
so much turnover in stories it was
always the same dominant story george
floyd's murder explodes the narrative
and uh and then but that becomes stuck
again too because that becomes a durable
story so
and then of course we get to the
election and things so you can quantify
the impression we all have that sort of
time froze once the pandemic hit
right and people said this they said you
know people say this anecdotally all the
time you know yesterday felt like a week
yeah i've got i saw one tweet was like
i'm gonna write an autobiography of my
last the last 10 years of my life it's
called 2020. you know like but you know
so i don't mean it's a very physics-ish
sort of thing like time dilation and so
on and but this was a memory you know at
the population scale
did things seem to really you know maybe
it wouldn't have maybe you know there is
this just sort of turn over it doesn't
really matter but in fact yeah 14 days
in april 2020 is kind of you would have
the same sort of turnover in two days in
2017. and
it's a weird it's a weird thing i know i
had david eagleman on the podcast a
while ago but like there's this weird
mismatch between
simultaneously one says nothing is
happening and time seems to last forever
right even though so the
the rate at which time passes is sort of
inverse to the
rapidity with which things happen an
exciting movie seems to go by very
quickly
yeah now that can be and it depends how
much you're recording you know in your
own mind right and there are studies of
how people yeah so when when something
and it's usually around something sort
of dire or terrible happening you know
an accident you have this
seeming slow-motion replay of it in your
head and it's because you were
really kind of writing down the memory i
mean that that's what i understand right
you were really recording it and kind of
you have it in fine detail but
there's a lot that goes on in life right
and we we know we miss most of it all
the sounds and the things you know they
just sort of pour past us there's a too
much to measure for one person so
our brains are pretty well
problematically good perhaps
at just ignoring things that don't fit
our little narrative right now i mean
there's certainly a lot that you know
that we've covered that is going on here
i do it's wonderful to have this
conversation because i get the
impression that a lot of the excitement
what you're doing is still ahead like
we've just started picking some of the
low-hanging fruit but i guess one final
question which you did allude to earlier
but
we can take these ideas and turn them
around and put them to work right i mean
maybe either in artificial intelligence
or in political campaigns or in writing
a screenplay you know like can we figure
out can we distill what would be the
perfect narrative or the perfect time
structure of valence or something like
that uh are people trying to
operationalize these ideas in that sense
yeah so there's a lot of work over the
years and and you can
maybe make a fair amount of money of
saying you can predict which things will
take off right because of your analytic
tool so it's you know it's i think i
think what we can do is
say look here's the shape of your story
you know here are the kind of tropes
you've used and so on and this is how it
compares to others around
and you know maybe give people a sort of
a diagnostic like that now in terms of
making something take off for sure
well so
this is the problem right reality is
socially constructed and we have older
work on
yeah we have older work on on fame and
and of course many people have kind of
come to this in different ways that that
show if you have kind of basically run
the world
over and over for cultural social things
it doesn't always there's a lot of
variability right harry potter doesn't
win in every
every universe it certainly didn't win
for the first 12 or 13
editors who said no right like how could
they not no how could they not know
right
they're professionals right but how
could they not know that this would be
this giant thing and that actually
indicates how much fortune and luck the
the fact that there's an enormous
runaway success
in something right the world is full of
these right whether the number one thing
is so much bigger than the second one
and the third one right these
heavy tail distributions
that
it's indicative of actually
what we'll tell is you know what
our simple story for that is the mona
lisa is fantastic for example like it is
intrinsically
amazing you know if you look at it you
will be transported and it's because of
this and this and this
but we just leave out completely the
social construction aspect it's because
you know it took 400 years to get to
that idea that it was the greatest
painting in the world um and there's
there's a whole sort of set of reasons
for why it became increasingly famous
that are
not intrinsic you know stories around it
but it's a good example of something
where you know you can't really kind of
i mean i guess that's the point like you
can't you try to make things as good as
that you can and you want them you want
to make them spreadable that's important
that people want to tell other people
about it i think that's the great
thing and of course that works for
disinformation as well
right so so what what will spread in the
social wild right this is the the great
problem of advertising right there's a
sort of
probably made up line but you know half
the money is wasted in advertising we
just don't know which half right and
and so and it you know it's sort of true
like like very unexpected things happen
and take off and and and how did you not
know that people well there's there's a
lot of social construction that goes on
but
so it wouldn't be anything that would
you know guarantee the future of
of some social phenomena but it would
serve as a i think conserve as a
diagnostic i i worry about the negative
aspects you know i mean
you know um
but i think we have like all of science
here we have to know that we have to we
have to know the things right so we can
start to build defense systems and i
think ai for example what we'll call ai
or sort of certainly the modern work
with um
with language and
all of these kind of
kind of crazy instruments you know
they've gotten a little they've gotten
way ahead of us right we're trying to
make decisions about you know in juries
or parole or something like that or
presenting things that turn out to be
deeply racist or whatever and you know
and and you know we've got this
we got ourselves
um way beyond describe and explain into
the sort of create category of of
science and
um you know we need we
i think i mean i think it's turning
around people are looking at the corpora
and someone that they've built some of
these systems out of and
uh you know i'm really
relieved to see that happen because i
think there was a wild time there and we
got ourselves uh you know like
facebook's algorithm right which things
spread right you have dials that you
turn to make certain things spread or
not spread
you can change the social contagion
there and that's
you know it's
yes there's money on one side but
there's also just you know does society
hold together on
on another side and i think that i guess
i think that's important i guess there's
also a feedback question right i mean
there's this
david lodge novel i read from the 80s
and he mentions very very early efforts
in uh
digital humanities where you would you
know digitize someone's book and figure
out what words they used more often than
than the typical english language and
this author was was shown you know that
you use the word
you know moist or whatever way more than
average and once he found out those
words he couldn't write anymore like
because he was too self-conscious about
doing it and i wonder if we figure out
too much about you know what the shapes
of these stories are and everything how
that's going to affect how we tell them
ourselves
yeah there's some peril there i suppose
um yeah scientists classic science moves
just look too deep it's like trying to
understand comedy and destroy everything
right so yes they need a joke
thanks thanks scientists
no i think i i would hope it would just
get i mean people are incredibly
creative you know people are incredibly
creative we find new ways to tell
stories we're we're in a time where we
have
so many stories in the past that we kind
of play with them and and so on it's
it's you know it's a i think it's
i i i
i don't i don't think it will we'll stop
all of that um it could produce it can
produce some stuff that's not very good
i think that's that maybe is the problem
well you try to build formulas too much
and so on so that that that could be a
slightly more dangerous fair enough well
all right i will just repeat thanks
scientists i like that as a motto uh and
peter dodds thanks very much for being
on the windscape podcast sean it's been
a great pleasure thank you
[Music]
you